[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halweg guten Abend ihnen allen und
willkommen alles Wichtige zum Fußball
hat nachher svenn Foss schönen guten
Abend ein besonderer Gedenktag
heute Synagogen brennen Juden werden
gejagt Geschäfte zerstört der 9 November
1938 die reich chomncht erinnern und
mahnen auch heute werden Jüdinnen und
Juden wieder zur Zielscheibe von Hass
und
Hetze strompreisbremse für Industrie und
Betriebe so will die Regierung den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
sichern und Happy End dank Harry Kane
2:1 gegen galatasarai und auch die
Bayern stehen im Achtelfinale der
Champions League
85 Jahre nach der reichsprromnach ägen
Entsetzen und Scham das Gedenken heute
vor 5 Wochen hätte er sich nicht
vorstellen können dass wieder eine Jagd
auf Juden in Deutschland stattfindet
heute sei er nicht mehr so sicher sagt
der Vorsitzende des Zentralrats der
Juden Josef
Schuster in der Nacht vom 9 auf den 10
November
1938 hatten von den Nationalsozialisten
organisierte schlägertrups Synagogen in
Brand gesteckt und tausende Jüdinnen und
Juden misshandelt verhaftet oder getötet
von der Gedenkveranstaltung heute
berichtet Roman
leskowa Margot Friedländer 102 Jahre alt
Überlebende des Holocaust eine der
wenigen noch lebenden Zeitzeugen der
Novemberpogrome Gast der heutigen
zentralen
Gedenkveranstaltung vor 85 Jahren
erreicht die Judenverfolgung im NS
Terrorstaat eine neue Dimension
angestachelt von der nsführung werden
Synagogen angezündet jüdische Geschäfte
zerstört Vorsitzende des Zentralrats der
Juden in Deutschland spricht in seiner
Rede von erneuten Ängsten tiefen
Traumata in der jüdischen Bevölkerung
nach dem hamasterror vom 7 Oktober
würden hier zu Lande wieder Häuser mit
Davidsternen bemalt Brandanschläge
verübt ist etwas aus den Fugen geraten
in diesem Land es ist noch die
Gelegenheit dies zu reparieren aber
dafür muss man sich auch eingestehen was
in den letzten Jahren schief gelaufen
ist was man nicht hat sehen können
oderoll
dazu gehört auch die Erkenntnis dass
hinter vorgehaltener Hand Antisemitismus
in Deutschland bis in die Mitte der
Gesellschaft vorgedrungen ist vor allem
Israel bezogene antisem Antisemitismus
wie sich zeigt in die hörseele in die
Theater auch in die bürgerlichen
vorstadthäuser der Bundeskanzler
bezeichnet die Ausgrenzung von Jüdinnen
und Juden auch heute als Schande dabei
dürfe es nicht darauf ankommen ob der
Antisemitismus politisch oder religiös
motiviert sei von rechts oder links
komme jede Form von Antisemitismus
vergiftet unsere Gesellschaft sowie
jetzt islamistische Demonstration und
Kundgebung wir dulden Antisemitismus
nicht das Versprechen nie
wieder dieses Versprechen müssen wir
gerade jetzt einlösen nie wieder das
steht an diesem Tag für viele
Gedenkveranstaltungen auch vor der
jüdischen Gemeinde zu Berlin 9 Dornbusch
Hellene geborene Reinhold zur Stunde
werden hier die Namen aller Berliner
Jüdinnen und Juden verlesen die im
Holocaust ums Leben
kamen im Bundestag war es heute
ungewöhnlich still bei der Debatte zum
Gedenktag auch die Abgeordneten zeigten
sich besorgt über den zunehmenden
Antisemitismus in Deutschland und riefen
zum Schütz jüdischen Lebens auf Andrea
Maurer das bundestagsgedenken an den 9
November
1938 ist überschattet vom Terror der
Hamas vom Antisemitismus auf deutschen
Straßen wenn jüdische Kinder Angst haben
müssen zur Kita und in die Schule zu
gehen wenn wir strengere
Sicherheitskonzepte brauchen um sie vor
Übergriffen auf dem Weg zum Unterricht
zu schützen meine Damen und Herren dann
beschämt mich das und es bricht mir das
Herz die Innenministerin kündigt weitere
Verbote von Organisationen an der grüne
Koalition dert weitergehende
Konsequenzen den gemeinsamen
Konsequenzen sollte auch eine
Überprüfung des Verhältnis zu
muslimischen Dachverbänden gehören erst
nach Aufforderung Antisemitismus auf
Deutsch verurteilen um danach auf
türkisch und arabisch das Gegenteil zu
sagen darf künftig nirgendswo mehr
durchgegangen lassen werden auch das
wäre praktizierte deutsche
staatsresort die Union verlangt härtere
Gesetze Stufen sie
Antisemitismus das schweren Fall der
Volksverhetzung ein und verhängen sie
eine mindestfreiheitsstrafe von 6
Monaten für diejenigen die gegen Israel
hetzen der Streit im Parlament dreht
sich auch um die Frage wo Antisemitismus
in Politik und Gesellschaft zu finden
ist diesen Antisemitismus der real
jüdisches Leben und die Existenz Israels
bedroht und auslöschen will finden wir
nicht unter der arbeitenden deutschen
Bevölkerung wir finden ihn in den
Moscheen in den Islam Verbänden und ein
an den linken Universitäten und in den
BDS verseuchten Kulturbetrieb Frau von
Storch hat ja eines in ihrer Rede
vergessen wenn ich es richtig sehe sie
haben ja eine Aufzählung gemacht wenn
ich es richtig sehe gibt es in
Deutschland nur eine Partei bei der
gegen Abgeordnete wegen antisemitischer
Straftaten ermittelt wird und das ist
ihre nie wieder ist jetzt das gibt
Bundestagspräsidentin Bars dem Parlament
und dem Land an diesem 9 November mit
auf den
Weg der 9 November steht auch für die
friedliche Revolution in der DDR und den
Fall der Mauer daran wurde heute
ebenfalls erinnert an der Gedenkstätte
Berliner Mauer gedachte der Regierende
Bürgermeister Wegner der Mauertoten
ebenso das norwegische Kronprinzen pa
HaCon und Mette Marit beide gerade zu
Besuch in Deutschland und und 300
Jugendliche aus mehreren Ländern vor 34
Jahren strömten tausende Menschen über
die Grenzen von Ost nach West Berlin
nicht lange danach war die DDR
Geschichte jetzt zum Krieg im Nahen
Osten da hat sich Israel nach US-Angaben
bereit erklärt täglich vierstündige
Kampfpausen im Norden des Gazastreifens
einzuführen das israelische Militär flog
auch am Abend Luftangriffe auf Gaza
Stadt zuvor gab es Berichte über heftige
Straßenkämpfe die Feuerpausen sollen es
Zivilisten ermöglichen aus dem Norden
des Gazastreifens Richtung Süden zu
fliehen
fragen wir Stefan Schlösser in Tel Aviv
wie weit sind diese
Verhandlungen im Hintergrund wird
offenbar ganz intensiv verhandelt unter
Vermittlung von Qatar Ägypten und den
USA zunächst diese Meldung zu den
vierstündigen täglichen humanitären
Pausen aus Diplomatenkreisen ist aber
auch zu hören dass über mehrtägige
Feuerpausen verhandelt wird im Gegenzug
könnten dann etwa 12 Geiseln
freigelassen werden die sich in der
Gewalt der Terroristen befinden es ist
auch zu hören dass das internationale
komite des Roten Kreuzes Zugang zu den
Geiseln erhalten soll denn bisher weiß
man ja gar nicht wie viele der
entführten aktuell überhaupt noch am
Leben sind sie werden seit über einem
Monat vermisst darunter mehrere Kinder
sogar ein neun Monate altes Baby und
dann gab es noch die Meldung vom
Islamischen Jihad auch beteiligt an den
Angriffen am 7 Oktober man sei bereits
zwei Geiseln freizulassen wenn
entsprechende Maßnahmen erfüllt sein
welche Maßnahmen das weiß man nicht
jedenfalls wurden ein Foto und ein Video
der 77 Jahre alten hannach Kir und des
12jährigen jagil Jakov veröffentlicht
die hier in den Medien bereits rauf und
runterlaufen das macht natürlich
Hoffnung gerade bei den Angehörigen aber
ob es am Ende tatsächlich zu einer
Freilassung kommt das kann man seriös
tatsächlich nicht beantworten die
Einschätzung live aus Tel Aviv danke
schön Stefan
Schlösser über aktuelle Entwicklung
informieren wir Sie jetzt auch auf
WhatsApp einfach unseren ZF heute Kanal
abonnieren wie das finden Sie in der
Einleitung auf unserer Homepage ZDF
heute und in unserer
App ein Booster für den Standort
Deutschland eine überfällige
Entscheidung so reagiert die Industrie
auf den Kompromiss den die
Bundesregierung beim industriestrompreis
gefunden hat nach monatelangem Streit
die Ampel will unter anderem die
Stromsteuer auf das europäische Minimum
für die Wirtschaft reduzieren Klaus hat
mehr sie sollen weniger bezahlen müssen
Unternehmen mit hohem Stromverbrauch und
internationaler Konkurrenz die ihren
Strom billiger bekommt anders als bisher
wird nun die gesamte produzierende
Industrie
entlastet davon profitiert der
Mittelstand und die Industrie und es
bleiben marktwirtschaftliche Anreize
erhalten denn wir garantieren keinen
Preis das bleibt Sache des Marktes aber
wir reduzieren den Anteil des Staates an
den Kosten die Steuer soll drastisch
gesenkt werden von 15,37 € auf 0,5 € pro
Megawattstunde also 0,05 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde bereits bestehende
entlastungsregelungen werden verlängert
Eigenanteile entfallen das bedeutet auch
weniger Bürokratie in 5 Jahren soll
diese Regelung wieder auslaufen die
Stromsteuer zu senken auf das
europäische Minimum ist eine sehr gute
Maßnahme wir schlagen das als
Sachverständigenrat schon sehr lange vor
eigentlich für die gesamte Wirtschaft
und auch die Haushalte es macht keinen
Sinn den Strom teuer zu lassen wenn wir
doch elektrifizieren wollen um in
Richtung Klimaneutralität uns zu bewegen
es ist gut dass die Industrieunternehmen
jetzt Klarheit haben an welcher Stelle
sie entlastet werden das war dringend
erforderlich Angesicht der hohen
Energiepreise und es ist gut dass hier
gerade auch die mittelständische
Industrie von dieser Senkung der
Stromsteuer profitiert die Union
hingegen kritisiert zu spät zu wenig
Entlastung für zu wenige brauchen auch
die Einbeziehung aller Unternehmen und
der Bürger es haben doch alle hohe
Stromkosten natürlich das produzierende
Gewerbe aber die anderen Betriebe auch
die Bürger auch es bezahlen auch alle
CO2 Preise günstigere Strompreise sollen
den Standort Deutschland stärken und so
Abwanderungen ins billigere Ausland
verhindern die Bundeswehr bekommt einen
neuen kernauftrag Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius will die Truppe konsequent auf
den Schutz Deutschland Land und seiner
Verbündeten ausrichten dazu soll etwa
bei den Reformen der Beschaffung Tempo
gemacht werden zur Begründung hieß es in
dem heute veröffentlichten
Grundsatzpapier Russland Bleibe ohne
einen fundamentalen inneren Wandel
dauerhaft die größte Bedrohung
Europas wenn die Bahn mit der
lockführergewerkschaft GDL
Tarifverhandlungen beginnt dann heißt
das in der Regel Streit auch heute zum
Auftag der Gespräche schwebt die
Streikdrohung gleich mit die GDL fordert
unter anderem eine Lohnerhöhung von
555 € einen
Inflationsausgleich von bis zu 3000 €
und die Wochenarbeitszeit für
Schichtarbeiter soll von 38 auf 35
Stunden sinken ohne Lohnkürzung über die
Verhandlungen jetzt Stefanie Heim die
Bahn legt gleich zu Beginn der
Gewerkschaft der Lockführer ein Angebot
vor bietet bei 32 Monaten Laufzeit 11%
mehr Lohn Plus inflationsprämie um noch
mal ein klares Signal zu setzen haben
wir heute der GDL auch angeboten dass
wir den Mitarbeitenden die unter die GDL
Tarifverträge fallen eine halbe
inflationsaussprämie also 1500 € im
Dezember ausbezahlen würden wenn die GDL
bereit ist dann auch über Weihnachten
hinweg Friedenspflicht mit uns zu
verabreden das hat sie abgelehnt es geht
der Gewerkschaft vor allem um 3 Stunden
weniger Wochenarbeitszeit im
Schichtdienst die Arbeitgeberseite hat
uns ein Angebot gemacht wo wir ganz klar
und eindeutig kommentieren zu wenig zu
lange und am Ende des Tages nicht
ausreichend wir werden den Druck auf dem
Kessel hochhalten und wir werden am Ende
des Prozesses zu jedem Zeitpunkt in der
Lage sein unsere Forderung auch mit
entsprechenden Streikmaßnahmen zu
untersetzen zwar betonen alle sie
wollten schnelle Abschlüsse trotzdem
könnten sich Verhandlungen oder Streiks
auch über Weihnachten ziehen oh nein
nicht um die Weihnachtszeit alle warten
darauf dass die Kinder nach Hause kommen
und dann um die Weihnachtszeit das finde
ich sehr lücklich gewählt jeder möchte
mehr verdienen das ist richtig aber man
muss auch im Verhältnis bleiben so ist
das halt wenn man was erreichen will
muss man manchmal irgendwie in
Widerstand gehen nächste Woche wird
weiter verhandelt doch kürzere
Arbeitszeiten würden laut Bahn viele
zusätzliche Mitarbeiter nötig machen bei
dem Fachkräftemangel sei das
undenkbar nach langem politischen
Tauziehen steht Spaniens offenbar kurz
vor einer Regierungsbildung und die
Aufregung ist groß denn die Sozialisten
haben für die Wiederwahl von
Ministerpräsident Sanchez ein sechs
Parteien Bündnis geschmiedet mit dabei
sind die katalanischen Separatisten die
im Gegenzug auf eine Amnestie für
1400 verurteilte Parteianhänger hoffen
dürfen auch für exregierungschef
putschdemont der im belgischen Exil
lebt an einer Schule im badischen
Offenburg hat ein 15-Jähriger auf einen
gleichaltrigen Mitschüler erschossen
geschossen dieser erlag im Krankenhaus
seinen schweren Verletzungen bei dem
Großeinsatz an der Förderschule für
lernschwache Kinder heute Mittag konnte
der Tatverdächtige festgenommen werden
die Polizei geht von einem Streit mit
persönlichem Hintergrund aus die Schule
wurde weiträumig abgesperrt undund 180
Schüler verschanzen sich zunächst in
ihren Klassenzimmern sie wurden später
aus dem Gebäude gebracht und
psychologisch betreut
in Europa sind ein Fünftel aller Tier
und Pflanzenarten vom Aussterben bedroht
das zeigt eine neue Studie an der auch
deutsche Wissenschaftler beteiligt waren
dabei sind wirbellose Tiere wie dieser
Feuerfalter besonders betroffen sie
verlieren ihren Lebensraum die Ursachen
sind vielfältig Andreas
Stamm Umweltverschmutzung
Industrialisierung
Intensivlandwirtschaft Gründe für eine
globale Umweltkrise das menschengemachte
Arten sterben das Ausmaß ist offenbar
größer als bisher angenommen eine
vielbeachtete Studie kommt zu
erschreckenden Ergebnissen in Europa
sind demnach etwa 27% der heimischen
Pflanzen vom Aussterben bedroht 24% der
wirbellosen Tiere dort vor allem
zahlreiche Insektenarten und 18% der
Wirbeltiere die Zahlen beruhen auf
umfangreichen Daten internationaler
Forscher so der Studienleiter die
meisten dieser Arten haben natürlich
Funktionen im Natur halt ja das heißt
wenn sie an die Fliegen denken die
vielleicht auf ihrem Kuchen sitzen die S
dort nicht mögen weil sie denken na ja
die saßen vorher vielleicht irgendwo auf
dem Haufen die sind aber sehr wichtig um
genau diesen Haufen zu beseitigen ja das
heißt ohne diese fliegen würden wir
praktisch im Dung unserer Haustiere
ersticken und ohne Bestäuber würden wir
natürlich keine Nahrungsmittel
produzieren können die Trockenheit rund
um Halle macht diesen Sommer die
schmetterlingssuche der Biologin
Elisabeth kühn schwierig kaum Erfolg geh
es den Faltern schlecht geh es dem
Ökosystem schlecht erklärt sie ein
erster Schritt wäre die Renaturierung im
großen Stil aber auch im heimischen
Garten einfach mal wachsen lassen und
das gilt sowohl für jeden einzelnen in
dem Garten oder in dem Vorgarten als
auch für Kommunen Gemeinden dass einfach
auch mal Blütenpflanzen stehen bleiben
damit die Nahrung weiter bleibt es gebe
viele erfolgreiche Lösungsansätze für
den Erhalt der Arten und Ökosysteme
ergänzt die Biologin und damit trotz
düsterer Zahlen Hoffnung für die
Lebensgrundlage der
cheint und jetzt Fußball Champions
League Sven auf den FC Bayern war
gestern wieder verlassen und auch wenn
sie nicht den ganz großen Glanz
verbreitet haben die Bayern stehen
wieder vorzeitig im Achtelfinale das 2:1
gegen galatasarai Istanbul war der
vierte Sieg im vierten Spiel in der
Gruppenphase Harry Kane sei Dank Tore
als Lehrbeispiele vom Phänomen Harry
Kane pfichtspieltreffer 18 und 19 in 15
Spielen Bestwert in Europa die Qualitä
hat er auf jeden Fall mit nach
Deutschland gebracht
er hat schon öfters unter Beweis
gestellt der 2:1 Sieg gegen galatasarai
mit einem starken Comeback von Manuel
Neuer auf internationalem Pakett ich bin
einfach froh dass ich dieses Gefühl mit
meinen Mannschaftskollegen dann teilen
kann und wir können stolz sein auf die
Leistung die wir bisher gezeigt haben
aber beim 17 Sieg nacheinander in der
Gruppenphase der Champions League fällt
musialer länger aus zum dritten Mal in
diesem Jahr der Oberschenkel das sieht
auf jeden Fall mal für Heidenheim ist
das ausgeschlossen Länderspielpause auch
für Kane gilt nur eine kurze torpause
nächster Gegner
Heidenheim alle Tore des vierten
spieltags in der Champions League können
Sie sich noch mal in der heute App
anschauen auch die vom Spiel Union
Berlin gegen Neapel nach 12
Pflichtspielniederlagen in Folge
erkämpften sich die Unioner ein ein zu
ein beim italienischen Meister ihr
erster Champions League pun uniona
jubeln ausgeschieden zwar aber
erleichtert war einfach mal wichtig
diesen Bann zu brechen sich auch mal ich
glaube für eine tolle Leistung zu
belohnen Neapel von Beginnern
torgefährlich aber Union defensiv stark
doch in der 39 Minute ist nicht zu
machen Matteo Politano trifft unhaltbar
zum 1:0 für Neapel auch in Halbzeit 2
verhindert Union einiges und dann
gelingt ihnen selbst der Konter und
David Fana in der 52 minute der
Ausgleich es bleibt beim ein Z ein
Niederlagenserie gestoppt als
Gruppenvierter geht es für Union jetzt
noch um die Teilnahme an der Europa
League das tut doch mal ganz gut Barbara
ja immer danke schön für den Sport bitte
zum ersten zum zweiten und dann hatte
jemand anonym einen Picasso ersteigert
und zwar das Gemälde Mädchen mit
Armbanduhr zeitlos wertvoll auf 120
Millionen Dollar hatte das Auktionshaus
sutherbeast das Werk von
1932 geschätzt den Zuschlag gab es bei
20 Millionen mehr das zweitteuerste je
ersteigerte picassowerk es zeigt Marie
Therese Voltaire eine Geliebte Picassos
mit der er eine Tochter hatte und die
ihm so lieb und teuer war dass er sie
auch in weiteren Werken
abbildete das Wetter bleibt herbstlich
mit neuem regen die Details hat gleich
östtin terli im heute journal um : Uhr
spricht marjetta Slomka mit NATO
Generalsekretär Stoltenberg wir sagen
danke und tschüss und Wünschen noch
einen schönen Abend bis morgen wenn Sie
[Musik]
mögen schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter das herbstliche
Wechselspiel aus nassen und trockenen
Phasen setzt sich fort denn weitere
Fronten überqueren uns und bringen Regen
im tagesverlau la ja und dieses Tief
hier vor allem dann zum Abend den neuen
Regen und dahinter kommt dann auch mal
etwas kühlere Luft ins Land in der Nacht
gibt es Regen und der überquert uns
ostwärts hier und da ist Blitz und
Donner vor allem im Westen dabei bei
tiefsten Temperaturen bis 0° am
Alpenrand hier generell kühler als sonst
im Land 8° im Osten noch am
mildesten morgen dann im Süden viele
Wolken und Regen das verabschiedet sich
allmählich ja ganz im Osten da ist es
eher trocken hier zeigt sich auch mal
die Sonne ansonsten kommt von Westen der
neue Regen auf ja und das bei höchsten
Temperaturen bis zu 12° im Osten
ansonsten 6° an den Alpen die nächsten
Tage weiterhin wechselhaft mit Regen 4
bis 10° am Samstag Sonntag einige
Auflockerungen mehr dabei und damit
einen schönen Abend